we have a new theatrically released
movie that was not released theatrically
because you know but it was released on
Netflix so it counts as a new movie so
hey let's talk about this movie so the
lovebirds is that movie that you saw the
trailer right I saw this trailer on so
many movies while they were still movie
theaters running movies you know the
trailer with that couple and the guys
like hey I'm a cop and then runs over
the guy on the bike he's like then
they're on the romantic comedy run he
gets kicked by a horse Jake the grease
that movie that that's this movie I
don't my saying I'm not usually good at
breaking down movie plots but that's
pretty much all you need to know about
the plies like someone kills someone and
then people think hey it's them and
they're like alright now we're on the
run to catch that person while the cops
are coming after them romantic comedy
101 just sounds like a rom-com adventure
but i say they're so good in this movie
together Kumail Nanjiani I hope I
pronounced that name right you know me
and names a nice array there so they
work so well together at the beginning
of the movie you see when they first
meet its really sweet they're on their
first date and four years later they're
you know they look like a couple who's
been in a relationship for a while
they're fighting they're bickering all
these problems bubbling to the surface
and then now they're on this adventure
and we're gonna see them get closer but
it's the banter between the two that I
just that kept me engaged with this
movie it wasn't for them I just feel
like this is a pretty forgettable movie
all things considered nothing in the
movie really stands out except these two
you can find other movies with the plot
afar at a couple on the run a comedy
with a couple on the run they go to some
creepy cult which I'm glad they changed
that line and the trailer she was like
I am a town IRA's in the trailer like
nuts more like eyes wide shut its mean I
get eyes wide shut is 20 years old you
don't want to be dated you don't want to
look old I'm not saying I was a
projectionists the movie theater and I
stood by that port window with that
volume up Oh teenagers Jeremy he learned
some things but they changed the line in
the movie to some Illuminati [ __ ]
because that's good because it's nothing
like Handmaid's Tale at all just an
observation maybe a bicker or a nitpick
in fact it has nothing to do with no
credible review would ever even mention
it but this movie actually has quite a
few chuckles in the movie as you're
along in this adventure no moments where
I was just dying of laughter there's no
just like laugh until you cry moment sir
quite a few chuckles and quite a few
more than I thought I was gonna get what
you say about the myth it's a simple
movie that's simple movie and you're
gonna get a simple review if being on
Netflix I popular on it was like just
shy of an hour and a half that's perfect
for a rom-com and you know those
romantic comedies you're like is this
two and a half fat why is it over two
hours long what are you making the Red
Dead Redemption two of romantic comedies
why is it that long this movies like
just shy of an hour and a half long hour
and a half is a perfect length of time
for a movie like this ready it does feel
like they rushed the end they were like
guys we're coming up on the hour and a
half so if you could just word vomit
some exposition speed it up sweet and
whoa we almost went over an hour and a
half that was close close but they did
and it keeps the movie in the pocket
it's simple
it doesn't generally stand out but our
two leads keep it from just being
completely forgettable
I suppose I'm being nice to this movie
because it's just on Netflix you just
hop on your couch pop it on it's on it's
free I know what you're thinking Netflix
isn't free what's free to you because
you're piggybacking off of your friends
Netflix account don't you lie I know you
you can't hide from me which I think
helps this movie because if this was
theatrically released when I'm like okay
well is it enjoyable I'm saying is it
enjoyable given the concept that you
have to get off your ass get ready get
in your car go to the movie theater wait
at the movie theater watch the movie you
got to pay 15 bucks for your movie
ticket there are logistics involved in
this movie you can do exactly what I did
look like a complete slob being your
robe just plop on your couch turn it on
it's on so I got a judge this movie Bay
on the reality we live in the reality we
live in is this movies pretty convenient
it's a fun movie to just have on kill
some time for an hour and a half while
you're watching it it's a pretty fun
time no alcohol required Isis a love
birds have you seen it why did you think
about it or actually or I heard Justice
League dark apocalypse war the animation
I can't just jump into it so what's the
viewing order because I've seen throne
of Atlantis and it actually sucked balls
compared to the Aquaman movie and the
throne of Atlantis comic books throne of
Atlantis the animation didn't hold a
candle to any of it so what's the
viewing order and what are the good ones
cuz I'd like to watch apocalypse war but
kind of out of the loop on the animation
so however you can help comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you